so I hope that all hear us so the whole point will give you the app I'll give
you around six to five tasks and then try to navigate as best as you can you
know this whole point the whole point of this thing is just to I guess just to
improve okay okay starting the first task first task is verify the
functionality of adding new recurring expenses and splitting it among
household members so the the details I want you to enter it's kind of already
fixed but the expense name is rent category is rent amount is 1,200 date is
the 31st 3 5 slash 0 5 24 we want to repeat it weekly and then split it with
three household members yeah that should just be that's that should be it
actually and then going to the second task ensure the functionality of paying
an existing tasks and verify it's removal from the list so what was your
trouble beforehand sorry all right yeah that's yeah it's more of a figma thing I
guess yep is it removed go perfect that's past three I'll say that's that's
two sir so that's three is a go back to the homepage please confirm the ability
of the ability to view past expenses and verify payment history yep and then
you want to navigate yes that should be it yeah that's good that's very fairly
intuitive go go back to the home page please task for validate the insights
features for the rent category and ensure accurate data visualization
visualization visualization okay yeah that's fairly good if you go back please
go back to the homepage okay that's five test the customization option for
display and X ability to ensure you suitability for all users so that
basically means try to change the colors of the app
can you try to put it back to the original color scheme and then test the
help and support functionality ensuring users can find information and contact
support if needed test the help and support functionalities ensuring users
can find information and contact support if needed
yes so you're supposed to navigate the settings right not that yet you are in
the right page to try to find information and contact support yeah if
you can try to input something yeah that should be everything actually oh thank
you you have any I guess final remarks would be expense thank you thank you
perfect thank you thank you for your time and that should be it